[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel heute zeige ich euch hier richtig
leckere kartoffel gesichter machen könnt
und dafür benötigt ihr 50 gramm
speisestärke 100 gramm käse und 500
gramm kartoffeln ich habe schon mal ins
wasser aufgesetzt und jetzt werden
kartoffeln schälen und dann
schütteln
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich meine ganze schaffen
geschält und jetzt will ich sie
[Musik]
ich
das schüttelt gerade die kartoffeln
damit sie halt wenn sie kochen dann
schnell natürlich sind
[Musik]
ich habe meine tasche hoffen jetzt
geschnitten und jetzt zunächst auch mehr
wasser hinein
[Musik]
comeback und war
ich habe es mir eine kopplung mit rolf
getan damit das nicht überkocht und
jetzt muss es 15 minuten lang könnte
okay ich habe jetzt meine kartoffeln
gekocht und jetzt tue ich sie ab gießen
[Musik]
jetzt zur presse ich mein gekochten
kartoffeln
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich noch die speisestärke und
inquisition
[Musik]
bis hin zu
ich glaube es ist besser wenn man
entweder der größere schüssel nimmt oder
ist auf der arbeitsfläche ausrollen
oder wie soll er gesagt
[Musik]
jetzt teile ich den teig in zwei hälften
und wollen dann aus
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt zwei aussetzer
besorgt also und ist zu einem spritzigen
gehirns aber das passt schon
also ich steche zuerst zwei also ein
kreis aus und dann mache ich halt
hiermit die augen
[Musik]
bakbasel
den restlichen teig können wir dann
wieder zusammen kneten und dann nochmal
ins rollen
b
wenn wir es machen wollt es ist nicht
schlimm dann kann sie auch einfach
sticks macht ich freu mich zuerst aus
und dann schneide ich dir herzlich
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt meine sticks und mais
und hosen für zehn bis zwanzig minuten
ins gefrierfach
ich habe jetzt meine kartoffel sechs
meine smiles rausgenommen außer gefahr
und jetzt habe ich mir eine besorgt
und jetzt wieder rein
[Musik]
comeback und war
okay
[Musik]
b
jetzt noch die restlichen fertig und
dann können wir schauen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt alles fertig frittiert
und jetzt habe ich gerade eben noch
einen kräuter dip gemacht und jetzt
brauche ich noch jemanden zum
anprobieren könnte rein
ich hab da der rhein also
ich hab da
kräuter richterin
oregano minze
und was ist und deswegen kartoffel mit
[Applaus]
susanna probiert einfach so cool los
ich nehme den hier sieht lecker aus ihm
gehört dass das herz für mich dass
papa
dort kann man
perfekt verläuft
ich gehe mit ihr laufen spielen das
ist echt gut
ich glaube ich nicht kenne auch bei
meiner schwester kommt
[Applaus]
findest du es
mit
wir sind
kirche so schwalb in
den kühlschrank
[Musik]
ich danke dir
dann
abspielen
[Musik]